[موسيقى]
خلال هذه الايام تتعامد الشمس على
المسطحات المائيه في البحر الاحمر فيتسبب
فوارق ضغطيه على صفحته اي مرتفع جوي في
اعلاه ومنخفض جوي في ادناه فيؤدي هذا
لهبوب رياح مثيره للغبار والاتربه لمده 60
يوما تقريبا على سواحله التهاميه في
السعوديه الى القرن الافريقي مرورا باليمن
هذا الغبار يسمى بموسم الغبيره او الغبره
والعامه يعرفون بدايه موسمه بنفضي ثمره
المسواك المسماه بالكبات يطربني والخيل
تعثر بالقنا حدات المنايا وارتعاج المواكب
وضرب وطعن تحت ظل عجاجه كجنح الدجى من
واقع ايت
السلاهد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وموسم الغبيره يؤثر على الليث والقنفذه
وجازان وسواحل التهاميه وكذلك حجه
والحديده باليمن يبدا نشاطها من المنقلب
الصيفي 22 يونيو ويمتد الى دخول موسم سهيل
وسهيل كوجنه الحب في اللون وقلب المحب
في الخفقان
[موسيقى]